foreign
[Music]
we've got a great show for you today and
a great cast of characters like the 10
year old girl who made a prehistoric
discovery on a beach why did she dig up
we'll tell you a group of teens who
helped the new kid in school in a major
way I love this story and meet the
founders of 826 an organization that has
open nine quirky shops across the
country from a superhero supplier to a
pirate store what is the purpose of
these Whimsical stores we'll let you
know plus some other of two experiencing
homelessness had to give up her beloved
dog but that's not where the story ends
it's happy and a bus that has gone to
the dogs where are they taking these
little babies we'll let you know on the
uplift
[Music]
hey
y'all it's David begno welcome to the
show that lifts you up for at least the
next 30 minutes we'll start with a story
about a homeless mom who could no longer
take care of her dog but when they
parted ways she left something behind
with her beloved pup here's Caitlin
O'Kane with their story
animal shelters are used to taking in
stray dogs but this pup named Lilo came
to mccammy Animal Center off the street
with an added surprise we received a
call from a Good Samaritan that there
was a large dog running around a
neighborhood and had a leash attached to
it so our animal protection team went
out and picked her up as the Stray and
when they put her on our truck to bring
her back to the center here is when we
found the note the note please love me
my mom can't keep me and is homeless
with two kids she tried her best but
can't get help I cost too much for her
she really loves me and I'm a great dog
it is one of the saddest things I've
ever read the last line is what really
hit us all here was please don't abuse
me
um when you looked at Leela you could
tell right away that she was very well
cared for and definitely loved that was
definitely the truth unfortunately many
dogs dropped off at shelters don't come
with notes so the staff was glad Lilo
came with a clue about her family a
shelter is not the same as a home so at
the end of the day we'd rather you keep
your pet and we're able to do whatever
we can to make sure that that happens
the shelter staff posted about Lilo on
social media hoping to connect with her
owner soon they got a call from someone
saying they were lilo's mom it was a
wonderful reunion it was very clear when
Lilo entered the room that that was
definitely her family everyone was
extremely happy there was not a dry eye
in the room
the kids were also just as excited and
emotional as everyone else while centers
like mccammy provide shelter for dogs
they also provide resources for families
who love their pets but might not be
able to keep them due to cost for this
family we are working with some local
agencies in town to help find them pet
friendly shelter for for other families
we've now established a new fund called
the Mac cares fund where we will be able
to help families whether that's paying
for a pet deposit at an apartment
complex providing food resources
anything like that to just try and keep
them together the goal of animal
shelters is to keep dogs like Lilo happy
and safe and sometimes that means going
above and beyond to reunite them with
the family that loves them
telling you that story touched me to my
soul thank you Caitlyn for that we take
you now to Alaska where a bus picks up
eager passengers each day to take them
on adventures with their friends it's
not your typical school bus and they're
not kids here's Natasha lorno every
morning in Alaska this cool bus makes
its round picking up passengers but
they're not kids going to school they're
dogs going on adventures good morning
Mario
hey buddy
the dogs jump into their assigned seats
and are attached to leashes instead of
seat belts
load up the doggy bus is operated by Mo
Mountain mutts a dog walking business
created by Mo Thompson and her husband
Lee I hope everybody enjoyed their trip
today and remember
your guide salary depends greatly upon
the quality of their service and the
generosity of your gratuity they loaded
their bus and take different groups of
dogs on off leash walks multiple times a
day the pups can expect the same
treatment as airline passengers thank
you for riding with moments would you
guys like a complimentary chicken liver
with your bus ride
and nobody ever says no to complementary
treats
they're even assigned very important
responsibilities please stay in your
seats till we get to your house pause to
yourself
Tails out of the aisles
Murray you're sitting in the emergency
exit are you willing and capable of
offloading the pups in a remote chance
of an emergency
thank you so in the back of my bus
there's four seats that are all by
themselves so they're literally in their
own little section we call the licky
puppy corner so dogs that want to like
relentlessly lick each other all sit
together and then the mentors and the
Really calm dogs sit together
the dogs are seated based on their
personality age and manners Nina and
Marie sit together they sit behind me
because they're very polite writers
they're not noisy nobody squeaks in my
ear or slaps me in the back of the head
with their big paws like these guys
definitely would hey you're gonna have
to get your seats while some dogs don't
always follow the rules excuse me ma'am
your tail is in the aisle
ma'am you're gonna have to adjust your
butt most of them are well behaved
running around the woods and on the
trails can be dangerous so before adding
a new dog to her pack Mo sets up a meet
and greet to test the dog's temperament
and make sure it is reliable and trained
for Regal Jake Maru
good dogs Mo and Lee never miss an
opportunity to make the doggies feel
special here we got the birthday boy his
name is gentleman Jake now we're bored
the puppy bus it's time for puppy cake
it's made just for dogs from Lucy's
Bakery and Jake says thank you for
celebrating me
one thing's for sure the dogs aren't the
only ones having a good
as Moe and Lee say they wouldn't trade
their job for anything in the world
[Music]
I'm so jealous why because I didn't get
to tell that story thank you Natasha
stick with us because after the break
we're going to take you to the beach
ready for some warmth right that's where
a 10 year old girl got a head start as a
paleontologist with a pretty impressive
Discovery in the sand come on back
[Music]
welcome back to the uplift a 10 year old
girl recently made the discovery of her
lifetime on a beach finding something
about 15 million years old
here's Jan Crawford with that story
Molly Sampson has a knack for finding
things I got you whether it's in her own
backyard or the Chesapeake Bay where she
and her sister like to hunt for fossils
so far she's found hundreds what do you
like about doing this it's just like a
treasure hunt and like they're really
fun to find like find and go hunt for
them recently Molly made the discovery
of a lifetime a prehistoric Megalodon
shark's tooth as big as her hand I felt
like a dream because I never thought I'd
find one that big like you couldn't
believe it yeah I couldn't believe it
myself because I've always said I've
never found one that big her parents
have been taking Molly to the beach
since before she could walk yeah I see
how valuable it was for me to be out and
have that experience of exploring and
looking for things it's just like fun
because their shirts teeth are really
old how old are you uh nine and how old
is that one 15 million years old she
says she may want to study paleontology
one day but in the meantime who knows
what else Molly will discover
I'm Gonna Catch You
the joys of Discovery thank you Jan and
Molly
we introduce you now to a woman who
started out as a street vendor at the
age of 12. now she pays homage to the
countless Street vendors in the City of
Angels Los Angeles here's Lilia Luciano
along one of downtown Los Angeles's
busiest intersections
a familiar scene
the often overlooked Street Bender
a fixture of the neighborhood Guadalupe
Faithfully set up shop on sidewalks
selling hot dogs five dollars a piece
five days a week for over 20 years
for artist Harry Torres
honoring La Street vendors is an ovation
to hard work and a nod to the staple of
the city that are these mobile Merchants
if you go everywhere and you see Street
vendors and they make the Landscapes of
Los Angeles she weaves her subject's
backstory into her work
etching words into the backdrop of The
Smiling entrepreneurs who pop up on the
brightly painted canvas some of them
actually have kids who are going to
University now and I'm a medium to share
their stories and also honoring them
with my art it's not just her passion
it's part of her story Doris's parents
proudly sold hot dogs on the street in
Colima Mexico and so did she so at 12
years old you were a street vending yeah
selling hot dog I was going to school
but my responsibility after school was
doing my homework and to help my parents
I didn't understand that until later
that they taught me how to make money
when she moved to the U.S at 18 the
sight and smell of Street vending were
welcome reminders of home and I thought
that it would be nice to actually have a
business as a street vendor I thought it
was going to be as easy as it is in
Mexico but it was not easy a lot of like
challenges a lot of people harassing you
it was a rough introduction but it gave
her a leg up in a new city and got her
saving for college where she eventually
earned a master's degree in art from Cal
State Northridge now the 34 year old's
work isn't contained to art shows
they're downtown on the side of city
buses and within the collection of
a-listers like Jennifer Lopez and I saw
by Netflix I'm like whoa let's win
Affleck but her work does more than
Adorn it Advocates
as a accountant because we are
supporting the economy the system that
value was recently acknowledged when
California's governor Gavin Newsom
signed a bill modernizing the state's
retail food code allowing food vendors
greater access to permits a reform
that'll Ease work for one of Taurus's
latest subjects Guadalupe
Decades of selling allowed the proud
mother of four to send all of her
children to college
from selling to painting to celebrating
Street vendors on canvas Torres has come
full circle if you're having a bad day
views can stop get the fruit get a
tamale get a champurrado that's where we
are there to create a Smiles on people
with great food they're a part of the
tapestry of Los Angeles and a very
important thread carefully woven into
her life too the good thing about being
an entrepreneur signs a kid is that you
learn how to wait
patiently for the things to come your
way
I want to say somebody who lives in Los
Angeles part-time and loves Southern
California thank you Lilia for telling
their stories we don't get to hear that
very often
from the uplift when a teen started at a
new School in Tennessee a group of kids
wanted to make him feel welcome so they
built him something that has changed his
life I'm telling you wait for it it's
next
thank you plus go inside a pirate supply
shop it looks quirky from the outside
but there's a lot more to this business
than meets the eye
[Music]
now look when I posted this next story
on my Facebook page it got 1.4 million
views okay we're going to take you to
Tennessee where I got a chance to meet a
group of high school students who built
something life-changing for the new kid
in town
meet 15 year old Sergio Peralta he's the
new kid at school and he started the
year with a secret the first season
school I honestly felt like hiding my
arm in my sleeve like nobody will ever
find out you know the elderly Flex this
joint you see Sergio was born with a
hand that didn't fully form so a teacher
at the Hendersonville High School
engineering program found out and he
told him my students might be able to
help you
and that's when three of them did
something special they ended up offering
me like we could build you a prosthetic
can and I never expected it like never
in a million years I expected it with
access to online models and a 3D printer
these teenagers who didn't even know if
their plan would work hit a home run
when I caught it the first time everyone
started freaking out because like it's
the first time I caught a ball in my
right hand in 15 years look school can
be cruel but these kids they did the
coolest and the kindest thing they
changed my life you know for their
newest Pier
the opposite of bullying is what those
kids did and it all started with that
teacher who got the ball rolling coming
up meet the people behind the 826
Network they run shops with Whimsical
themes like pirate spies and superheroes
but they have a much bigger purpose what
is it we'll tell you when we come back
[Music]
and finally let's Head West to a quirky
store in San Francisco that appears to
sell you everything you need to be a
pirate that's just the tip of the
iceberg here's Jeff glor with that story
walk into 826 Valencia Street in San
Francisco and you'll find what's
believed to be the only store in the
world entirely dedicated to selling
pirate supplies
but get beyond that and you soon realize
the point of this place is not to Hawk
fake gold coins
it is to deliver very real dreams I
wanted the place to be weird we wanted
it to be kind of homey and strange and
totally unexpected and have a sense of
humor because kids are so funny they're
so strange and funny and we so rarely
Embrace that and reflect it back to them
a pirate's life for me the weird
storefronts have become a staple at 826
writing centers around the world from
secret agents in Chicago okay are you
guys ready ready to go through the
secret passageway
to superheroes in Brooklyn a time travel
mart in Los Angeles and a woodland
creature Outfitter store at their newest
location in San Francisco when you
create a place that is profoundly
beautiful and wonderful and surprising
and young people walk through that space
it's a transformative experience for
them and it sends them the message
something's going to be different here
over the past 20 years 826 has become
the largest youth Writing Center in the
world if you could talk to your ancestor
what would you ask them matching up
volunteer tutors I would ask them what
were they eating in the old time oh
really with students in under-resourced
communities all free of charge
founded by Dave Eggers a Nineveh
kalagari the current director is beta
nazarian a former School principal I
think that's what 826 does so well is it
says students voices matter
here's the support you need as a teacher
as a young person in our system and then
let's publish you Edgar's first major
success in the publishing world was the
Memoir a heartbreaking Work of
Staggering Genius the book turned him
into a literary Superstar
and he soon discovered he knew lots of
others who were looking for ways to
contribute to their communities
kaligari was a teacher working in a
school overwhelmed with too many
students I had 146 students and any one
given time I never had enough time to
give them the attention I thought they
deserved and I just knew that teachers
out there would be super thirsty for
this service and and that was true Jimmy
and Latifah were two of the students
there when we visited High person
reading this I'll be telling you in my
in my own words how I see the future
they shared some of their own published
works on a lonely land I care for my
grandma sis Mom Grandpa and myself
because they're my family do you think
it's cool to see your name in print yes
I mean you get it it's a nice feeling it
kind of reflects it's a flex yeah it
very much is a flex yeah there's a
confidence and a calm that comes over a
published Young author because they feel
like I got it right I put it on paper
it's in this book that's my truth it's
there permanently Osvaldo Marquez Gomez
is a former student he's been published
11 times what did 826 do that the
schools couldn't it was that one-on-one
intention I had a hard time asking for
help so once a tutor is visual like
visually sitting there and like what's
going on like what are you processing
what questions do you have so like that
proactive like one-on-one attention is I
feel like that goes a long way it's
pretty wild to think like you see the
student 15 20 years ago and then he's my
boss now yeah he's your boss yeah on the
board sits on the board of directors
Oswaldo now helps oversee a writing
program at a time when there were 2500
documented cases of books being banned
last year an all-time high
Eggers recently joined that list he was
really surprised I had to that my book
The Circle was banned in a school
district in Rapid City South Dakota I
had to look back at the book to figure
out what there was and that I don't
remember anything and it would have been
objectionable but I was there a couple
weeks ago and talking to teachers and
talking to students and we had amazing
sessions and the teachers are incredibly
resilient they're finding ways around it
is not meant to replace the education
system but supplement it in ways most
schools can't
and it's about the people who are
willing to give their time to help these
kids find a voice
and in the process
maybe ReDiscover their own
[Music]
what the 826 tutors taught me and what
Dave has brought to the world is this
huge reminder that learning is also
joyful and I think that public school
teachers are doing their best in in
difficult circumstances and I do think
when there's so much stress and strain
on that system that it is it is
difficult to remember that that learning
can be joyful and that it could be
driven by love and kindness
love that joyful indeed it is that is
our show it's been a joy for me to join
you I hope this brightened your day and
lifted you up I'll see you next time
[Music]